bonsoir et bienvenue dans sa vous
regarde une émission spéciale à nouveau
ce soir consacrée à la crise ouverte en
macronie la loi immigration est passée
mais à quel prix la majorité se déchire
le ministre de la Santé démissionne
certains départements refusent
d'appliquer la loi et le rassemblement
national jubile alors comment rebondir
est-on à un point de bascule du
quinquena le piège de Marine Le Pen
s'est-il refermé sur le pouvoir 1 heure
en direct avec nos invités place au
débat tout de
[Musique]
suite la loi est désormais derrière nous
c'est ce que répète et surtout ce
qu'espère le gouvernement mais c cette
page de la loi immigration sera sans
doute la plus difficile à tournée du
quinquena jusqu'ù ira l'onde de choc
dans la majorité il y aura-t-il un avant
et un après vote du 19 décembre 2023
Emmanuel Macron prend la parole ce soir
sur le service public pour retrouver
notamment la confiance des siens et vous
en êtes Antoine Armand bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être là député renaissance de
Haute Savoie et porte-parole du groupe
macroniste à l'Assemblée vous débattez
ce soir avec Philippe Balard bonsoir
merci d'être là député rassembl national
de loise porte-parole du RN bonsoir
philippe Juvin bons bienvenue députés
les républicains des hautes scènes enfin
bonsoir Philippe brin beaucoup de
Philippe ce soir vous êtes député
socialiste de l'heure je vous donne la
parole messieurs dans un tout petit
instant mais on va commencer par planter
le décor de cette nouvelle journée
politique avec beaucoup de
rebondissement la majorité fracturée
c'est dans le billet de Valérie
Brochard et bonsoir ma chère Valérie
bonsoir Miriam bonsoir à tous déchire la
macronie au lendemain du vote mais oui
vous savez Miriam les fait àoche avec
ses grandes réunions de famille autour
d'un bon repas alors parfois ça se passe
bien c'est rare he souvent dans ces
grandes réunions de famille bien on
s'engueule on se déchire il y a toujours
un sujet qui fâche et pour la grande
famille Renaissance et bien c'est la loi
immigration alors entre ceux qui bouent
ceux qui quittent la table et ceux qui
chouinent et bien c'est le chef de
famille qui a fini par taper du point
sur la table il y a quelques instants en
direct depuis l'Élysée chez nos conf
frère de cet avou Emmanuel Macron a
déclaré avoir beaucoup de respect pour
tous les députés de la majorité qui ont
considéré que c'était une loi utile et
au fond un bouclier qui nous manquait il
faut assumer ce qui s'est passé et aussi
calmer les esprits très bien alors sur
la table on a mis les assiettes les
ronds de serviettes mais une chaise
restera vide regardez d'abord je vous
confirme la démission du ministre chargé
de la santé et de la prévention Aurélien
Rousseau qui a présenté sa démission à
la première ministre et au président de
la République et qui était absent ce
matin en conseil des ministres alors
aurélien rousseo est allé au bout de de
sa démarche mais hier soir ils étaient
plusieurs à vouloir quitter le
gouvernement enfin en tout cas à y
songer puis finalement à rentrer dans le
rang ça nous fait donc un absent et des
mécontents regardez Myriam 59 députés de
la majorité se sont abstenus ont voté
contre le texte hier dans l'hémicycle
parmi eux certains élus du MoDem les
cousins germains de la famille
Renaissance pas d'hésitation euh pour
pour différentes raisons pour des
raisons tenants à certaines dispositions
du texte d'ailleurs dont je n'ai aucun
doute que le Conseil constitutionnel les
censurera ça fait donc un/art de la
majorité qui n'a pas voté le texte et
pour le grand oncle le patron du MoDem
oui la famille est bien fracturée la
situation ne me convient pas alors parce
que on vit une période de désordre et il
faut se
méfier extrêmement du désordre quand
dans une démocratie ou une société de
liberté le désordre s'introduit dans les
esprits alors le risque est très grand
un risque mais quel risque une crise
mais de quelle crise parle-ton vous
savez ça c'est c'est la tata qui vapte
en bout de table vous voyez évidemment
de qui je je veux parler qui voit
toujours le verre à moitié plein qui met
un petit peu les sujets qui fâchent sous
le tapis vous allez la reconnaître ça
fait un an qu'on parle de ce texte qu'il
faut qu'on puisse passer à autre chose
qu' y a des sujets de préoccupation des
Français dont on doit pouvoir s'occuper
et moi je suis contente aujourd'hui
qu'on ait pu faire adopter un texte dont
on va regarder chacune des mesures qui
pourront être adaptées le cas échéant
mais on a pu avancer et maintenant on va
passer à autre chose allez hop circuler
on emmène la bûche de Noël et tout va
rentrer dans l'ordre mais quelle famille
va- ton retrouver Myriam après les fêtes
une famille décomposé recomposé les
beaux frères de droite seront-ils invité
à la galette de janvier si vous avez la
réponse sur ce plateau Miriam n'hésitez
pas à m'en parler merci pour ce billet
généalogique famille aller mordant comme
chaque soir Valérie Brochard Armand
pardonnez-moi Antoine Armand je vais
commencer avec vous je crois que vous
êtes un pur macroniste vous n'avez pas
milité avant au Parti socialiste ou chez
les républicains vous êtes engagé pour
Emmanuel Macron au nom du dépassement
d'éclivage gauche- droite c'est bien ça
absolument vous n'avez aucun problème de
conscience avec ce texte qui porte qui
penche clairement à droite ça c'est les
républicains qui ont tenu la plume vous
n'avez aucun problème de conscience deux
choses d'abord si j'avais eu un problème
de conscience je ne l'aurais pas voté et
je ne seraai pas sur ce plateau ici pour
assumer mon vote parce que c'est notre
responsabilité à tous d'assumer le vote
notre vote et d'assumer le vote de
l'ensemble d'un texte il y a des choses
que vous n'aimez pas dans ce texte il y
a des choses que je n'aime pas dans ce
texte il y a des choses qui me
paraissent
anticonstitutionnelles il y a des choses
qui ne sont pas des mesures que je porte
et que le macronisme porte le président
de la République lui-même a évoqué la
caution que le gouvernement exécutif qui
est à la main qui est à la main en la
matière pour fixer le montant va tout
faire pour min minimiser il y a les
allocations on en parlera plus tard donc
il y a des choses que je n'aime pas dans
ce texte mais pour répondre à votre
question très clairement qu'est-ce que
je me suis dit hier soir je me suis dit
voilà un sujet l'immigration sur lequel
nous avons deux urgences une urgence de
fermeté expulser des étrangers
délinquants c'est plus de 4000 étrangers
supplémentaires qu'on va pouvoir
expulser regrouper un certain nombre de
procédures contentieuses pour pouvoir
aller plus vite enfin ne pas avoir des
tribunaux administratifs des cours
engorgés et ne pas être capable de
donner rapidement une réponse aux gens
et puis une urgence de sortir de ce que
j'appellerai la zone grise qu'est-ce que
c'est la zone grise la zone grise c'est
une situation sédimentée depuis des
décennies par des majorités de droite et
puis des majorités de gauche qui n'ont
pas voulu apporter une réponse à à la
régularisation de certains travailleurs
sans papier qui trim qui bossent qui
Cotis fait ce que les autres n'ont
jamais fait nche je finis ma phrase pour
pour être tout à fait concret je suis
navré et donc il y a ces deux
radicalités il y a ces deux nécessités
là et c'est ces deux nécessités là elles
sont dans le texte d'hier et c'est pour
cela pour ce texte pour ces nécessités
que j'ai voté et je voudrais le dire
parce que contre cela que
59 59 députés dans votre camp la
majorité on n pas V ce TEX été fait avec
beaucoup de de réussite par votre le
malais ça vous le reconnaissez ce billet
il illustre quelque chose d'intéressant
le décalage complet entre les débats que
nous avons depuis lundi et ce que nous
disent les Français et les messages que
je reçois je reçois des messages de gens
mécontents de du vote de stect et je
reçois des messages de gens qui me
disent tu as bien fait c'était
nécessaire mais les gens dans les deux
cas ils me parlent des mesures ils me
parlent de l'expulsion des étrangers
délinquants il me parle de la question
des allocations il me parle de choses
concrètes donc ne nous trompons pas
ayons un débat politique constructif sur
le fond que certains n'ont pas voté vous
le savez on va pas refaire le match de
l'ensemble des mesures mais si vous avez
59 députés qui se sont abstenus VO
contre de l'ensemble des différentes
composantes de cette majorité ça
s'appelle comment ça s'appelle une crise
ça s'appelle une frontte quel mot vous
mettez sur cette forme de de cission ça
s'appelle une expression libre et
respectable et je suis désolé de le dire
nous avons voté des dizaines de textes
ensemble depuis 1 an et demi depuis
presque 2 ans maintenant il il y a un
texte sur lequel certains ont choisi de
s'abstenir certains ont choisi de voter
contre j'aimerais savoir qui Jama
conuise paril depuis début du premier qu
il y a quand même un ministre qui sort
aujourd'hui Aurélien Rousseau vous avez
raison mais deux choses premièrement
c'est un sujet éminidemment crispant
vous parliez de repas de famille je
pense que chacun dans Cees repas de
famille il y aura des discussions animer
sur le sujet et puis la deuxième chose
c'est que c'est le fruit d'un compromis
c'est dans un contexte politique et
notre responsabilité c'était un accord
demandé par les français ou pas d'accord
j'ai tranché je va faire CER la parole
mais c'est important parce que
aujourd'hui on voit vraiment que
l'actualité ce sont ces déchirements là
il y a deux personnalités que ne
connaissent pas bien les Français et qui
pourtant font figure je dirais de
macronistes historiques ils ont
participé à l'aventure de la première
heure ils ont construit le programme ils
font partie de l'ADN je veux parler de
Jean-Marc Borello le président du Groupe
SOS et de Philippe Granjon ancien
conseiller spécial d'Emmanuel Macron ce
sont des piliers et Cuxa disent
aujourd'hui ça ne va pas je suis mal à
l'aise ils ne sont pas députés mais ils
auraient voté contre qu'est-ce que ça
signifie politiquement sur votre
histoire politique mais ce que ça
signifie c'est que nous sommes ce n'est
un scoop pour personne autour de cette
table depuis juin 2022 en majorité
relative et qu'en majorité relative on
fait des compromis quand on estime
devoir être courageux est-ce que tout me
plaît dans ce texte est-ce que j'aurais
porté chacune de ces mesures
individuellement non est-ce que pour
autant je vais rejeter un texte qui me
paraît utile non et je vais vous dire
c'est ça qui nous demande nos
concitoyens c'est pour ça
vous traversez un moment quel est ce
moment quel mot vous mettez c'est un
moment de difficulté c'est un compromis
qui ne plaît pas à tout le monde c'est
une crise qu'est-ce que quel mot vous
mettez sur ce moment politique
particulier on traverse un moment où
chacun a fait preuve de courage la large
majorité de notre mouvement a voté pour
ce texte courageusement en se disant
qu'il était nécessaire et certains ont
eu le courage de poursuivre leurs
opinions et je je ce seraai pas celui
qui qui leur jette la pierre ce soir
Philippe Ballard c'était aussi
l'objectif du rassemblement national que
de faire imploser cette cette majorité
non de faire imploser bah oui d'une
certaine manière est-ce que c'est pas
tout est bon pour obtenir le chaos
maximal en macronie non pas du tout nous
ça fait un an et demi que je suis député
je me souviens très bien de ce qu'a dit
nous a dit au 88 député rassemblement
national Marine Le Pen dans vos votes il
y a qu'un seul vous avez une seule
boussole c'est l'intérêt de la France
l'intérêt des Français voilà c'est pour
ça que hier nous avons voté ce texte on
a plus une balance pour reprendre une
image puis vous savez il y a deux
plateaux alors il y a un plateau où il y
a certaines de nos mesures d'ailleurs
moi je lisais le monde vous l'avourz
c'est pas un organe c'est pas l'organe
de presse du rassemblement national et
qui disait ça ressemble à un tracte du
rassemblement national donc il y a des
mesures qui sont inspirées de du
programme de Marine Le Pen de 2022 du
programme actuel du rassemblement
national et puis de l'autre côté
effectivement il y avait cette
régularisation mais le texte a été durci
en CMP exemple concret on ne peut plus
être régulariser si on a un casier
judiciaire parce qu'on était quand même
jusqu'à hier on va voir après ce que
donne le texte notamment après le
passage en Conseil constitutionnel on
pouvait être régularisé avec un casier
judiciaire enfin voilà ainsi va la
France donc on a souosé tout ça et
arrivé donc sur la question des
régularisations des sansapiers dans les
métiers en tension le la CMP a durci par
rapport à la version du Sénat retaillo
par rapport c'est pour ça que no
sénateur l'avait pas voté absolument Lig
rou les préfets maintenant vous allez
régulariser des clandestins mais vérité
les les préfets vont observer cas par
cas et ça sera nonoosable c'est-à-dire
si un préfet dit non il y aura pas
d'appel possible ça
aussi à côté de ça il y a des mesures
que l'on réclame donc moi je me vois pas
demain je vais dans ma circonscription
je vais rencontrer mes électeurs j'ai
été élu avec 56 % donc j'ai beaucoup
d'électeurs qui me trouent très
sympathique et je me voyez pas leur dire
écoutez là effectivement ça va dans le
bon sens mais non on n' pas voté parce
que c'est un texte qui de la CMP
principalement vous saviez très bien
Philip ballar en votant pour le texte
cétait le baiser de la mort ça fait
partie de la tactique vous avez V Peet
calcul aussi vousvourz mais on raisonne
pas on raisonne pas comme ça après
effectivement il y a une crise politique
là enfin quand vous avez un ministre qui
démissionne 25 % de vos députés qui
votent pas le texte il y a quelque chose
qui va pas on pourrait peut-être
dissoudre d'ailleurs tiens ça serait pas
mal ça ouais vous la demandz toujours
cette dissolution philippe Juvin la
droite c'est l'architecte du compromis
en CMP les républicains ont tenu la
plume et c'est le rassemblement national
qui récupère la victoire ça doit être
vraiment rageant non ce soir pour vous
non nous voulionss un texte qui diminue
l'immigration légale et illégale les
deux donc ce texte nous l'avons c'est
nous qui l'avons écrit majoritairement
bien sûr il y a eu des négociations en
CMP mais c'est vrai c'est un texte les
républicains donc évidemment nous nous
satisfaisons cette chose deuxème point
moi je suis quand même frappé de tous
ces gens qui chouinent et disent ah j'ai
voté mais je suis pas content et cetera
dans cette affaire je vais vous dire il
y en a qu'un qui a eu du courage c'est
Aurélien Rousseau je suis à l'opposé de
ce qu'il pense puisque que moi je
soutiens le texte que lui il combat mais
lui au moins il a le courage de dire je
suis pas d'accord je m'en vais vous TRZ
que les autres ministres qui menacent de
démissionner sont quoi alors je ne juge
personne je dis simplement qu'uréliia
rousseo a eu du courage voilà et je veux
lui rendre hommage c'est un adversaire
politique qui rend hommage à un deuxième
un autre adversaire politique mais je
veux dire aussi une
chose on a l'impression de vivre un
psychodrame mais ce qu'on vit là c'est
d'une grande banalité dans toutes les
démocraties parlementaire quand il y a
pas de majorité absolue en Allemagne en
Suisse au Danemark qu'est-ce qui se
passe et bien il y a des accords
politiques il y a des négociations entre
des partis de majorité relativ et des
partis d'opposition et on essaie de com
de construire quelque chose j'ai été 10
ans députés européen au Parlement
européen il n'y a jamais de majorité
absolue comment fait-on on discute entre
les groupes et on construit quelque
chose il se trouve que cette fois-ci
c'est vrai pour des raisons
conjoncturelles créit vous allez
renaître de vos cendres pour la
prochaine présidentielle à partir de ce
compromis madame moi ce qui m'importe
c'est c'est le salut du pays on voit
bien comme le pays va mal le pays avait
besoin d'une loi qui diminue
l'immigration légale et illégale nous
avons fait cette loi nous nous en
satisfaisons il y a qu'un gagnant dans
cette affaire c'est la France et les
Français et moi je m'en réjouis Philipp
brin c'est intéressant d'aller chercher
la comparaison avec l'Europe avec le
Parlement européen c'est vrai que c'est
le compromis c'est ce qu'ils ont demandé
les Français trois blocs qui doivent
forcément s'entendre pour dégager une
une majorité ça n'est pas votre famille
politique mais ça s'appelle un compromis
est-ce que ça vous reconnaissez la
démocratie à parler qu'il faille trouver
des compromis on est évidemment d'accord
je rappelle que dans la commission mixte
paritaire il y avait d'ailleurs des
députés des sénateurs de gauche et ce
que je constate c'est que le
gouvernement la majorité n'a pas
souhaité discuter avec nous et que
l'équilibre du texte on doit aujourd'hui
le dire a été bien modifié bien modifié
de sorte qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un
texte qui est un musée des horreurs dont
la première ministre d'ailleurs convient
elle-même qu'il va être censuré entre 50
et 70 % sont les analystes les mots que
vous utilisez sont très forts he la
nausée loi de la honte il y a même une
sénatrice socialiste qui a cité
Churchill aujourd'hui au Sénat la
fameuse phrase sur la guerre et le
déshonneur on en est là vraiment en tout
cas et si vous regardez quand même ce
qui a été voté très concrètement donc il
y a les ce qu'on raconte sur les a les
prestation sociale avec une
discrimination pour ceux qui sont
arrivés récemment sur notre pays et puis
il y a par exemple un article on a pas
beaucoup parlé c'est l'article 19 terre
a j'invite les gens qui nous regardent à
aller regarder qui en fait interdit
l'hébergement d'urgence pour les
personnes qui sont en situation
irrégulière et qui ont passé le délai
d'exécution de leur obligation de
quitter le territoire français c'estàd
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes une personne
étrangère en France vous avez une
obligation de quitit le territoire
français pour x ou y raison vous n'avez
pas été expulsé c'est c'est écrit noir
sur blanc dans le texte et bien vous
n'aurez même pas le droit à avoir un
gymnase avec des lit Picot l'hiver pour
dormir ça veut dire que si cette
personne se présente aujourd'hui alors
qu'elle fait l'objet d'unqtf dans un
gymnase qui fait office d'ébergement
d'urgence est
pas le droit à l'hébergement d'urgence
c'est l'article 19 TER a c'est une
horreur et il y a d'autres horreurs
comme C et la prre ministre elle-même
c'est quand même extraordinaire la
première ministre le dit monsieur
balanan l'a dit le rapporteur le dit le
président de la commission des lois n'a
même pas voté ce texte tellement il est
mal écrit tellement c'est un compromis
de bout de table un espèce de trac du
rassemblement national VO bien qu' un
malaise il y a 59 députés qui ont voté
contre Aurélien Rousseau c'est pas
n'importe qui aujourd'hui Aurélien
Rousseau c'est quand même l'ancien
directeur de cabinet d'Élisabeth borne
la première ministre donc c'est pas un
petit ministre qui était là depuis
seulement 3 mois et ne se voyait pas
être le ministre qui cesse de finalement
prendre en charge la santé des étrangers
et on voit qu' va avoir une grave crise
sanitaire à la suite de cette réforme de
laame qui a été promise noir sur blanc
par la première ministre dans une lettre
suppression mais une réforme
répz bien on voit bien à quel point
aujourd'hui le gouvernement a atteint un
point de non retour moral et qu' essaie
de se il demande au Conseil
constitutionnel de régler ses problèmes
il a fait des promesses au députés LR
pour obtenir leur vote et aujourd'hui il
demande finalement il implore Laurent
fabus de nettoyer ce texte et toutes les
orreurs qui contient alors c'est
intéressant on va rebondir sur le
Conseil constitutionnel parce que c'est
vrai que que ce soit côté opposition de
gauche et même chez les républicains il
y a une inquiétude qui monte pour des
raisons diverses sur le rôle que vous
voulez faire jouer au Conseil
constitutionnel je vais vous citer Bruno
rotaillot dans un tweet vous savez que
il porte une partie de la paternité de
ce compromis il explique que tout semble
indiquer qu'Emmanuel Macron a donné pour
consigne de tout faire pour que la loi
immigration ne soit pas appliquée si
c'est le cas ce serait un abus
d'autorité inacceptable nous passerions
alors d'une crise politique à un grave
problème démocratique Antoine Armand
est-ce que vous n'avez pas au fond remis
sur les épaules du Conseil
constitutionnel l'objectif de nettoyer
le texte des mesures qui vous gênent
d'abord un mot quand même sur ce qui
vient d'être dit un mot sur ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est mon analyse chacun a
son opinion je pense que ce qui vient
d'être dit illustre malheureusement et
je le regrette d'ailleurs que ce soit le
cas parce que dans notre équilibre
politique c'est délétaire illustre la
une des raisons pour lesquelles le Parti
socialiste est part est passé de 20 30 %
à 2 %. c'est parce qu'il y a un refus de
se confronter au réel de quoi de quel
réel monsieur qu parle le réel le réel
c'est la question migratoire en France
avec tout tous ces aspects c'estàdire
avec le besoin de fermeté et puis le
besoin de
sortir
terveléil vous
plîe fait pas
comm quand il quand il s agit à
l'Assemblée nationale de discuter du
texte vous nous avez vous avez voté avec
les oppositions de droite le rejet et
vous avez demandé le retrait du texte
vous ne voulez pas discuter
d'immigration et je pense que c'est
terrible et je vais vous dire moi je
suis député d'ANC à an il y a des gens
de gauche des électeurs de gauche qui me
disent moi j'ai besoin qu'on parle
d'immigration il y a pas de tabou à
avoir on peut pas ne pas en parler et
donc c'est indispensable d'en parler et
donc les coups de moraline à longueur de
journée
je les mots de la langue française
n'appartiennent à personne alors
répondez là-dessus l'argument moral qui
fait qu'on étouffe la question
Mo pourement moi j'ai pitié pour lui
vous avez vu ses circonvolutions et ses
difficultés à expliquer ce vote moi j'ai
pitié pour lui et j'ai pitié pour les
engagements qui sont les siens et pour
son sens de la République aujourd'hui il
y a 59 députés de la majorité qui ont eu
le courage de s'opposer à ce texte sur
la question de l'immigration nous on a
fait des proposition évidemment qu'il
faut une loi sur l'immigration en France
pour nettoyer ce code de l'entrée du
séjour et des étrangers du droit d'asile
qui a beaucoup trop de titre de séjour
aujourd'hui pour exécuter les
obligations de quitter le territoire
français le gouvernement est en place
depuis 7 ans maintenant il n était
incapable d'exécuter les obligations de
quitter le territoire français il y a
10000 aujourd'hui étrangers qui relève
pas de la loi c'est une question quoi
d'efficacité 10000 étranger aujourd'hui
qui menacent l'ordre public qui sont pas
explosés on en a explosé que 3500 et là
ils n'ont aucune réponse là-dessus alors
vous pouvez faire des lois pour durcir
les choses pour les étrangers qui sont
sur place et qui sont souvent bien
intégrés et qui travaillent mais c'est
pas ça la solution il faut aujourd'hui
exécuter les alors terire franis et
gvernement est malheureusement incapable
je voudrais qu'on avance parce
qu'aujourd'hui le combat ne semble pas
complètement terminé on a parlé du
Conseil constitutionnel est-ce qu'on est
avec Stéphane Troussel le président du
Département de de la scène saintden
bonsoir merci d'être là président
socialiste de la SA sen les départements
ont la charge de verser certaines aides
sociales comme la loocation d'autonomie
pour les personnes âgées la loi
immigration exclu du dispositif les
étrangers en situation régulière présent
depuis moins de 5 ans c'est l'une des
mesures les plus clivantes du texte vous
ne l'appliquerez pas c'est bien ça
oui en tout cas avec une trentaine de
départements l'ensemble des départements
de gauche nous avons décidé que et bien
nous mettrons en place une
prestation extralégale une prestation
volontariste qui permettra de compenser
la perte de cette allocation d'autonomie
pour les personnes âgées qui en seraient
privées si cette loi euh immigration
devait s'appliquer je très concrètement
monsieur président Troussel ça concerne
beaucoup de bénéficiaires parce qu'il y
a beaucoup d'étrangers en situation
régulière qui percevit cette aide aux
personnes âgées et qui sont là depuis
moins de 5 ans mais bien évidemment que
non et c'est d'ailleurs bien la
l'illustration que cette ce texte cette
loi elle s'appuie surtout sur des
préjugés sur des préjugés raciste et
xénophobe sur un texte qui fait
finalement de la peur de l'autre de
l'étranger l' et l'oméga de de de de son
fondement et donc votre question est
tout à fait juste il faut savoir par
exemple que la moyenne d'âge des
bénéficiaires de la pas dans notre pays
c'est 82 ans 82 ans 72 % des
bénéficiaaires de la pas sont des femmes
et donc qu'est-ce qu'imaginent les
rédacteurs de l'extrême droite qui ont
tenu la plume de cette loi qu'il y
aurait des hordes de personnes âgées
dépendantes en perte d'autonomie qui
vont traverser la Méditerranée sur des
bateaux de fortune pour venir la
percevoir parce que de quoi s'agit-il
avec cette aide c'est une aide qui est
versée à des gens qui ont des faibles
ressources qui ont travaillé dur qui ont
été abîmés par la vie par la vie
professionnelle et qui ne sont plus en
situation d'effecter d'effectuer par
eux-mêmes les gestes de la vie
quotidienne faire leur toilettes se
nourrir se vêtir faire leurs courses
faire leur ménage et voilà ce que les
rédacteurs de cette loi imaginent
supprimer pour les bén même si ça ne
concerne que très peu de cas vous
appelez dans les départements de gauche
ou pas d'ailleurs à la desésobéissance
civile non non madame vous savez en
politique chacun est responsable de ses
actes d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
saluer l'acte courageux et qui lui fait
honneur de d'Aurélien Rousseau qui a
démissionné du gouvernement parce que
justement il est responsable de ses
actes et il ne transige pas sur ses
valeurs et bien moi je suis responsable
des miens et donc moi je je ne
distinguerai pas la possibilité de
percevoir cette aide pour des personnes
âgées vieillissantes en perte
d'autonomie je ne distinguerai pas entre
les citoyens et donc et bien je créerai
cette prestation comme il en existe qui
sont volontaristes euh et vous savez
tous les actes des collectivités locales
peuvent être contestés par le préfet au
titre de leur légalité et bien si
c'était le cas nous irons plaider notre
cause auprès du Tribunal Administratif
merci beaucoup Stéphane Rousel je
rappelle que près de la moitié he des
départements de gauche sont sur votre
ligne et veulent d'une certaine façon
créer une autre prestation pour
contourner la loi sans directement ne
pas l'appliquer philippe Juvin le
bouclier républicain c'est ça
l'expression consacrée se lève dans les
territoires par les élus locaux écoutez
madame moi je n'ai aucune leçon de
morale à à recevoir le bouclier
républicain signifierait que tous ceux
qui ne sont pas de la vie de Monsieur
Troussel donc ne sont pas républicains
tout ça est absurde ne repose sur rien
je dis premièrement que une loi a était
votée dans les règles par l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat c'est donc une loi
de la République ceux qui ne veulent pas
l'appliquer se mettent en dehors de la
République ça c'est vrai deuxièmement
dire que un étranger qui arrive sur le
territoire national n'a pas les mêmes
droits que les Français n'est pas un
scandale la France a le droit de décider
qui a quoi comme droit et j'ajoute même
que c'est tout à fait compatible avec le
droit européen en Allemagne depuis
maintenant plus de 10 ans et si je faire
mon pédent juridique je pourrais vous
rappeler qu'il y a un arrêt de la Cour
de justice de l'Union européenne de 2014
l'arrêt d'anneau qui dit très clairement
qu'un État peut décider de faire
profiter d'une prestation sociale un un
citoyen qui n'est pas qui n'a pas sa
citoyenneté qui a un étranger nous
sommes tout à fait nous avons tout à
fait le droit de faire ça nous voulons
simplement dire une chose c'est quand on
arrive sur le territoire national de qu
figure soit on ne travaille pas ben
quand on ne travaille pas pardon et
qu'on arrive sur le territoire national
on ne bénéficie pas des prestations
sociales durant 5 ans la France c'est
pas un pays où on arrive on se met sur
le cadapé et on regarde Netflix toute la
journée pendant ça s'appelle de la
préférence nationale mais madame je vous
pose la question différenciz entre les
Français et les étrangers en situation
régulière bien entendu il y a des il y a
des des droits qui sont donnés aux
Français qui ne sont pas donnés aux
étrangers j'ai le droit de vote un
étranger n'a pas le droit de vote ça
dépend s'il est dans l'Union européenne
il peut voter au EUR d'accord enfin il y
a une différence le RSA vous êtes
étrangers vous n'avez pas accès au RSA
immédiatement donc arrêtez d'expliquer
que c'est c'est le drame absolu ça se
fait dans tous les pays moi j'explique
rien question tous les pays du monde ont
des droits différenciés entre ceux qui
ont la citoyenneté du pays du pays qui
accueille et ceux qui arrivent sur le
territoire quant à ceux qui arrivent sur
le territoire national et qui
travaillent ils ont des ils auront des
prestations sociales qui seront différés
dans le temps à condition qu'ils
travaillent et après qu'ils aient montré
qu'ils voulaient travailler la France
n'est pas un pays où on arrive on se
pose et on se dit bah que les
allocations les prestations tombent non
c'est pas comme ça la France c'est un
pays très généreux madame mais madame
non mais endez je vous pose une question
qu' n'y ait pas de différence sur en
matière migratoire entre le RN et vous
c'est une question parce que c'est vrai
que après tout vous avez le droit de
partager des idées des solutions pour le
pays je ne vais pas vous dire que je me
base je me compare à moi je vous donne
ma réponse je ne vais pas me comparer à
tel ou tel parti je vous dis ce que nous
pensons cela fait des années que nous
mettons sur la table l'idée assez simple
que la France a le droit de décider qui
bénéficie de ces prestations sociales et
qui n'en bénéficie pas en l'occurrence
pour bénéficier des prestations sociales
il faut être sur le territoire national
et travailler et puis quand on ne
travaille pas on attend un peu plus
longtemps tout ça est tout à fait
logique j'ajoute qu'avec 3000 milliards
de dettes madame la France est dans un
état économique que nous connaissons qui
peut-être nous pousse à avoir une vision
un peu sage de la dépense publique voilà
h Philippe bal bah déjà je pense que la
juridiction administrative va avoir son
moi à dire après moi j'ai une autre
remarque c'est imaginez un maire
rassemblement national
qui même cas de figure disent moi je
vais faire un bouclier à ma sauce en
quelque sorte mais al qu'allons-nous
entendre ça va être terrible ça va être
terrible là parce que ils ont une
sensibilité où ils sont étiquetés à
gauche là ça passe Crand même et puis
bah on les applauditf faut déjà avoir ça
présent à l'esprit ensuite oui nous on
est pour la priorité nationale c'est pas
un gros mot pour nous c'est les nôtres
avant les autres donc oui bah quand on
arrive de l'étranger on n' pas les mêmes
droits que quand on est Fran
compromis sur les aides sociales vous
semble trop généreux encore pour les
étrangers en situation régulière ou ça
va dans le bon sens mais c'est encore
évidemment beaucoup trop généreux la
question du logement par exemple vous
savez que en situation régulière quand
on travaille si on arrive pas à trouver
un logement et qu'on a pas les moyens le
risque c'est la chapelle les tentes et
les sans abri et la difficulté il y a un
tiers desement HLM qui sont occupés par
des immigrés il y a des Français qui
dorment dans leur voiture le soir oui
moi je connais même des policiers qui
dorment dans leur voiture le soir parce
qu'ils ne trouvent pas de de logement
donc oui oui on assume complètement
c'est la priorité nationale faut bien
comprendre qu'on a plus rien à offrir à
ces personnesl enfin problème crise du
logement crise de l'immobilier du
logement parce que là on cumule les deux
en France le système de santé c'est pas
mon collègue Juvin que je vais l'
prendre quand même on est dans le faussé
système éducatif s'ffondre complètement
et puis je nous on fait le lien comme le
préfet de police de Paris entre
immigration et sécurité le préfet de
police de Paris qui nous dit la moitié
des personnes mises en cause en
Île-de-France mais c'est la même chose à
Marseille c'est la même chose à Lyon
sont des personnes étrangères voilà donc
faut avoir tout ça en tête et là on a
gagné effectivement une victoire
idéologique hier victoire idéologique
vous savez que le risque c'est
l'original et la copie on préfère
toujours l'original vous prenez un très
très gros risque quand même avec ce
texte la la victoire idéologique du Ren
je mets les guillemets associé c'est un
détournement c'est un détournement
inventé lundi soir par le rassemblement
national et soutenu et diffusé par
laanupes
pourquoi pour justifier un double
abandon une double désertion le
rassemblement national parle matin midi
et soir d'immigration il explique à son
électorat et aux Français que c'est le
problème principal que font-ils il
votent une motion pour ne pas débattre
de l'immigration dans l'Assemblée
nationale il rejetteent au Sénat trois
sénateurs RN rejettent au Sénat un texte
dit dur sur l'immigration et il vote
ensuite en catastrophe se rendant compte
de grossière dit la première ministre on
va y revenir parce qu'on va regarder un
sujet précis sur la stratégie déstion
abandon et puis abandon Monsieur B
disait qu'il voulait pas voter pour
voilà et puis abandon de l'autre part de
la L qui refusé et qui du coup tente
d'alimenter cette rumeur pourquoi à
nouveau pour placer sur un pseudo
terrain moral des arguments des des des
débats qui devrait être sur des mesures
de fond ce qui intéresse les Français
allez alors on est bien mesure de fond
je voudrais qu'on s'arrête un instant
sur cette fameuse caution exigée au aux
étudiants étrangers elle ne passe pas
dans les universités elle ne passe pas
dans les grandes écoles vous avez sans
doute vu la tribune dans Le Parisien des
dirigeants de l'ESSC de l' SCP de HC qui
dénonce très vivement cette mesure même
le président de la République n'y est
pas favorable ce texte nous pousse à
faire une croix sur lapport de talent
Antoine Armand pourquoi vous avez voté
je le rappelle vous avez voté cette
mesure pourquoi cette mesure ne passe
pas chez moi non plus je ne pense pas
que ce soit une bonne mesure je je pas
j'ai pas j'ai pas besoin de comment on
peut voter un texte quand on considère
qu' qu'il y a une mauvaise mesure dedans
et ben je vais vous expliquer je vais
vous expliquer dans ce texte on peut
régulariser jusqu'à 10000 personnes par
an qui travaillent qui cotisent qui
contribuent à l'effort national dans ce
texte on peut expulser 4000 étrangers
délinquants supplémentaires qui
représent une une menace c'est le prix à
payer la caution dont on parle la
première ministre l'a évoqué ce matin à
la radio elle envisage puisque c'est la
prérogative de l'exécutif de la fixer de
10 à 20 € je vous interromp pour plus de
clarté pour ceux qui nous regardent
Antoine on va l'écouter et je vous redne
la parole juste après cette caution qui
manifestement déjà un peu de plomb dans
l'aile la première ministre ce matin
chez nos confrères de France Inter le
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur
peut en dispenser des gens en fonction
de leur revenus ou en fonction et et en
fonction de leur parcours méritant
scolaire ou universitaire est-ce que
c'est une bonne formule on va en
reparler elle sera combien la caution ça
peut être 10 € 20
€. vous avez écrit une un texte pour une
ction 10
un texte réglementaire voilà est-ce que
est-ce que on n'est pas dans au fond la
limite la limite du compromis avec cette
mesure- làà précisément qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé je sais pas à la Chaîne
Parlementaire que je vais expliquer ça
il y a une commission mixte paritaire il
y a un débat chacun arrive en disant
telle ou telle proposition doit figurer
dans le texte les républicains nous
disent voilà nous il faut qu'il y ait
une caution pour les étudiants extra
européen dedans et ce sera renvoyé à un
texte réglementaire pour son montant
nous nous disons c'est tout à fait
envisageable nous savons c'est
gouvernementa et quand les quand les les
grandes écoles les universites on réagit
ils connaissaient pas le montant et
l'ampleur de ce que ça pouvait pr PhIP
Juvin vous vous êtes fait avoir sur la
caution je sais pas si on s'est fait
j'espère d'abord que la loi ne sera pas
détournée parce que c'est un grand c'est
un grand classique c'est un sujet
d'ailleurs dans notre Constitution c'est
le poids du règlement du décret par
rapport à la loi il faut pas que la loi
le décret dénature la loi parce que
sinon il y a un sujet non je voudrais
revenir sur le fond parce que c'est ça
qui m'intéresse premièrement quand on a
augmenté les les les les taux
d'inscription les coûts d'inscription
pour les étudiants étrangers en 2018 ça
n'a pas du tout diminué le nombre
d'étudiants ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point aujourd'hui les étudiants
c'est le flux le plus important de
d'immigrés légaux en France voilà c'est
devenu P qu'il des AB c'est ça
troisièmement nous voulons nous des
étudiants parce que nous pensons qu'il
faut aller chercher les talents partout
nous y avons intérêt le pays a intérêt à
avoir des talents mais nous voulons
faire la chasse aux faux étudiants et la
réalité c'est qu'il y a les universités
sont dans l'incapacité de de pister
entre guillemets les faux des vrais de
ceux qui s'inscrivent et ensuite qui ne
suivent pas d'études on a un vrai sujet
là-dessus enfin 4è point nulle part au
monde madame nulle part au monde le le
fait de devoir payer a dissuader les
meilleurs étudiants de venir le vrai
sujet c'est pas d'avoir des étudiants
c'est avoir de bons étudiants les
grandes universités américaines et les
grandes universités britanques font
payer mais il absolument 5500000
étudiants étrangers en Grande-Bretagne
550000 madame avec des des des des coûts
d'inscription qui sont très élevés ce
qui montre bien c'est ce modè là que
vous souhaitez non non mais je vous dis
ce qui vous montre que le coût la
question du coût n'est pas la question
clé de la limitation du nombre
d'étudiants et particulièrement de leur
niveau et enfin en Allemagne il y a une
caution pareillement qui est de 11000 €
donc je je crois que c'est une peut-être
une une simplicité de l'esprit un
raccourci un peu facile que de prétendre
que parce qu'il va y avoir une caution
on'ura plus d'étudiants ce n'est pas
vrai les faits montrent
que ca diminue probablement les
étudiants de faible niveau mais les
étudiants de mon niveau ils viennent
parce que c'est une manière de de les de
les filtrer donc je pense que ça serait
une grave erreur de faire une caution à
10 € parce que ça signifie qu'en réité
on s'ass bien compris on verra ce qu'il
en ce qu'il en devient de cette cette
caution et et le Conseil constitutionnel
parce que l'histoire n'est pas terminée
manifestement cont compte tenu des voilà
des des différents des différentes
instances qui vont se pencher maintenant
sur ce texte on en vient pour terminer à
la stratégie du rassemblement national
qui se retrouve vous l'avez tous compris
au centre du jeu après le vote de de
cette loi immigration victoire
idéologique ou victoire tactique élément
de réponse avec Clément pergau
regardez lundi 11 décembre l'examen du
projet de loi immigration s'ouvre en
séance publique dans l'hémicycle les
regards sont déjà braqués sur eux les
députés du rassemblement national
prépare un coup
politique réunis quelques minutes avant
la séance ils sont arrivés sans un mot
pour les journalistes rien ne filtre
encore de leurs intentions alors qu'une
motion de rejet du texte va être soumise
au vote tout le monde s'interroge sur la
stratégie du
RN
votre texte est invotable pour les
députés dun car il va à l'encontre des
attentes des Français grâce au voix du
RN la motion de rejet est adoptée à la
surprise générale Marine Le Pen ressort
triomphante bien plus prolix cette fois
devant les
journalistes que ce gouvernement cro que
la politique c'est du rodéo s'agit de
rester sur le
Chevalme de vous
éjecter
surise placé au centre de l'attention en
attendant l'acte 2 alors que sénateurs
et députés tentent de s'accorder en
commission mixte paritaire hier matin
encore le parti semblait se diriger vers
une abstention ou un vote négatif je le
dis si les mesures qui visent à
faciliter la régularisation d'immigrés
clandestins sur le sol français sont
retiré nous pourrions voter ce texte je
l'ai dit depuis le départ si ces mesures
sont à l'in c'est une ligne rouge et
bien on s'abstiendra ou on votera contre
ce texte quelques heures plus tard alors
que les mesures de régularisation des s-
papiers figurent toujours dans la
version finale nouveau rebondissement
sous la pression je crois de l'électorat
du rassemblement national cette loi
devient une loi de durcissement des
condition de l'immigration nous allons
donc voter baiser de la mort l'annonce
va en tout cas faire son effet la
majorité tankque sérieusement àors de
voter le texte avec l'appui du RN vos
sénateur RN on v contre le texte du
Sénat voilà un Mo désormais c'est le
texte du Sénat 15 mesures symboli et
vous votez pour pour qui vous nous
prenez vous avez dit pendant des mois
des semaines et des années que vous
voteriez aucune mesure de régularisation
s papier et vous allez voter
manifestement 10000 régularisation de s
papiers par an bravo avec ces deux coups
politiques le RN a marqué les esprits
sur la forme sur le fond malgré une
victoire idéologique
revendiqué
tjours éé d'unarté
év il a pas tort Clément per la ligne
politique n'a pas toujours été très
claire Philippe Ballard est-ce que vous
n'avez pas cédé au plaisir du coup
politique du baiser de la mort par
rapport à une cohérence traditionnelle
vous le dites vous-même régulariser
c'est nonom est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
dans la récupération tout simplement je
vousou l'ai expliquer tout à l'heure
regarde la seule chose la seule boussole
c'est l'intérêt des Français dans ce
texte là il y a la régularisation des
travers sans papier pour pourquoi nos
sénateurs ont vé compte parce que il n'y
avait pas je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure cette mesure qui est quand même
très forte on peut pas régulariser
quelqu'un qui a un casier judiciaire et
il ne pourra pas y avoir appel après la
décision du préfet et quand on v a
beaucoup de préfets qui auraiit
régularisé sans la loi je pense qu'ils
ont quand
même moi je fais confiance au préfet si
vous voulez c'est tout simplement alors
après moi je y a de certificat par
exemple de l'employeur ne sera plus
nécessaire non
mais c'est c'est plutôt une bonne chose
après un projet de loi un projet de loi
il y a plusieurs articles et on a fait
on a mis tout dans la balance et ça
penche du côté on vote parce que ça va
dans l'intérêt de la France on va vers
la priorité nationale même si ce mot est
frais et je les comprends la majorité
enfin la majorité qui n'est pas qui n'a
plus de majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
mais ça va dans le dans le bon sens
alors après deux choses rapement il y a
des sondages qui ont été qui sont sortis
aujourd'hui sonag élab 74 64 % des
personnes interrogé estime que le
rassemblement national sort renforcé cet
épisode et 73 % que cette ce projet été
inspiré par le rassemblement national
puis un sondage CSA aujourd'hui 71 % de
personnes interrogées disent oui à la
priorité nationale donc je pense que ça
nous donne tout ça plutôt plutôt raison
il vous crédit et c'est quand même les
LR qui ont fait le boulot vous le
reconnaissez ça parce qu'ils ont dû
quand même pas malasser
n bah oui pourquoi on nous a pas vu
parce qu'il y a 7 députés se sénateurs
il y avait
c'est bien ce que je dis donc vous
n'avez pas participé aux discussions qui
ont permis d'éblir la lo
doncurais all
aussi nous av écrous après ce qu'a fait
le LR moi je alors je pense que vous
avez lu la proposition de loi d'éotti
qu' a présenté il y a un an que vous
avez acheté des photosopieuses quand
même à l'Assemblée nationale parce que
c'est un copier collé du programme
présidentiel Marine Le Pen et enfin
touché par la grâce vous avez compris
que il faudrait faire un référendum mais
surtout parce que on a parlé réforme
constitionnelle VO voilà mais ça c'est
le point essentiel par ça fait 45
minutes effectivement mais ça vous AZ
peut-être pu le faire quand vous étiez
au pouvoir ça fait 45 minutes qu'on
parle mais on n pas abordé le point
essentiel c'est sans réforme
constitutionnelle tout ce qu'on fait là
depuis des jours à l'Assemblée mais
c'est du vent on est dans l'écume des
choses parce que si on ne se met pas à
l'abri de la Cour européenne de justice
de la Cour Européenne des droitsomme
toutes ces juridictions qui nous
arrivent vous reconnaissez quand même
que la question migrair Monsieur B
question migratoire elle joue on c'est
un bouclier qu'on aurait en France si on
changer la Constitution pour faire en
sorte une phrase que la norme suprême
c'est notre Constitution soit supérieure
à toutes ces jurisprudences ça il faut
que vous répondiez là-dessus parce que
on est quasiment au cœur du débat
présidentiel de 2027 cette question elle
va revenir et d'ailleurs la
présidentielle à venir à peser sur ce
compromis et sur cette loi immigration
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à Philippe B
bon je comprends que le rassemblement
national veuilleent se mettre à l'abri
de la justice je sais que il y a des
choses assez dramatiques qui vont vous
arriver avec les assistants
parlementaires au Parlement euré je
pense qu'il y a des choses qui sont qui
sont embarrassantes et qui contribuent
au climat que vous essayez d'introduire
qui est en fait une contestation des
juges une contestation de l'État de
droit et une contestation de nos
institutions c'est ça la musique qui a
derrière je vous rappelle que le
Président de la République avait ouvert
la porte à référendum sur l'immigration
Rint par d'aut chose on parle de ceè non
on par de se soustraire aux juridictions
européennes comme d'autres pays de
l'Union européenne qui oui la cour de
carchrou par exemple en Allemagne et le
Danemark enfin voilà je pourrais
multiplier les exemples vous bon bref on
va y revenir donc là le cadre européen
et ses juridictions sur le fond du sujet
est-ce que nous sommes favorables à une
révision constitutionnelle pour
s'extraire des traités européens qui
garantissent les droits de l'homme et la
la qualité de nos institutions
démocratiques évidemment non évidemment
non et on voit bien le jeu de
surencherre et le décalage progressif
vers la la sortie des institutions quels
autres mouvements politiques en Europe
demandent la sortie de ces institutions
et de cet État de droit et bien ce sont
les populistes de
Victor extrémistes polonais que vous
citiez les populistes au Pays-Bas
gervilders a été élu premier ministre de
de à la Hollande quand on regarde la
campagne et je m'adresse à vous philippe
Juvin c'est très frappant je m'adresse
aussi à vous Philippe brin de voir que
tous les candidats se sont droitisés
tous les candidats y compris les socios
démocrate ont fait une campagne sur le
zéro immigration et qui a gagné c'est
celui qui historiquement portait ce
thème-l de façon la plus ferme philippe
Juvin vous répondez l'original a été
préféré à la copie vous risquez la même
chose en 2027 vous répondrez aussi juste
après Philippe brin mais madame moi j'ai
été candidat au prima de la droite
pendant les primaires de la droite j'ai
proposé c'était il y a 2 ans les
prestations social différencié donc je
ne fais que voter aujourd'hui ce que je
proposais il y a quelques années
premièrement de FO vous reconnaissez que
le rassemblement national est beaucoup
plus audible que vous sur ces thèmesl je
reconnais ce que vous voulez ou voulez
pas mais il faut regarder les choses non
mais moi je regarde les choses en face
ce texte qui a été adopté hier par
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat c'est
un texte des républicains maintenant que
tout le monde veuille sans partager la
paternité après avoir rejeté le bébé
quelques heures avant monsieur Bardella
disait je vais pas le voter les
sénateurs rassemblement national n'ont
pas voté ce texte donc qu'ils ai fait un
coup c'est la politique très bien c'est
ils ont fait un coup moi ce qui
m'importe c'est que ce texte va
améliorer le quotidien des Français
c'est un texte qui est un tournant qui
ne ne satisfaa pas tout parce que nous
pensons au républicains qu'il faut
effectivement modifier la Constitution
il y a une semaine une semaine c'était
pas il y a 10 ans les républicains ont
mis sur la table à l'Assemblée nationale
un texte de révision constitutionnelle
ce texte n'a pas été adopté à quelques
voies mais vous n'étiez pas là tous les
rassemblement national soi-disant très
attachés à cette r vision
constitutionnelle pour le voter donc moi
je vous le dis très simplement nous
avons amélioré les choses ça ne suffit
pas et il y aura d'autres étapes les
positionnement géomé en particulier nous
voulons dénoncer l'accord
franco-algérien de 68 qui comme vous le
savez font fait aujourd'hui que les
Algériens sont quasiment exclu de toute
loi sur l'immigration et puis il y aura
le sujet européen sur Frontex Frontex
qui devrait être une agence de garde
frontière qui est devenue aujourd'hui
une quasi agence humanitaire pH j'ai
promis la parole à Philippe brin oui bon
d'abord c'est intéressant c'est faire de
révisions constitutionnelle parce que
quand on interroge les auteurs ils sont
incapables de nous dire qu'est-ce qu'il
faut changer en vérité vraiment dans la
Constitution qu'est-ce qui est empêché
par notre cadre actuel et aujourd'hui la
loi immigration les partis qui vont être
censuré vont être censurer sur quel
fondement sur le fondement de la
Déclaration des droits de l'hommme et du
Citoyen donc c'est pas un texte européen
écrit en polonais qui va interdire qui
va censurer la loi immigration c'est la
déclaration de Dr du citoyen alors si le
Front National et les le parti dit les
républicains ont un problème avec la
déclaration dans l'omme du citoyens
c'est quand même inquiétant et et vous
avez raison de dire que je crois que les
victoires culturelles précèdent toujours
les victoires politiques et quand les
uns et les autres nous laissons des
centimètres finalement à ce que nous
pensons réellement car moi j'ai la
conviction que dans la majorité
présidentielle ils sont pas d'extrême
droite et qu'ils sont majoritairement
Mme s'ils essa de le cacher très mal à
l'aise avec ce texte et bien je crois
que quand on fait cela effectivement on
fait prospérer les autres je donne pas
de leçon car l'explosion du
rassemblement national dans notre pays
on en a tous une responsabilité et la
gauche en particulier et je crois le
rassemtional pousse sur les terrains que
nous laissons en jacher et aujourd'hui
il est temps je crois de relever la tête
la République les valeurs
républgalité de
tous écé Emmanuel Macron le soir de sa
victoire deuxè victoire à la
présidentielle en 2022 le président de
la
République je sais
aussi que nombre de nos compatriotes ont
voté ce jour pour moi non pour soutenir
les idées que je porte on est là mais
pour faire barrage à celle de l'extrême
droite
ou et je veux
ici les remercier et leur dire que j'ai
conscience que ce vote m'oblige pour les
années à venir voilà ce vote m'oblige
pour les années à venir vous allez
réagir Antoine Armand le barrage
républicain vous êtes socialiste si
demain en 2027 Marine Le Pen se retrouve
face à un candidat qui n'est pas
socialiste qui n'est pas de la gauche
mais qui est du bloc central vous ferez
barrage à nouveau ou pour vous il y a un
précédent qui s'est créé sur
l'immigration il n'y aura plus de
barrage pour vous c'est une question
précise donc répondez-moi précis bien
sûr bah écoutez moi
aujourd'hui évidemment que je ferai
toujours barrage au rassemblement
national d'accord maintenant est-ce que
je vais réussir à convaincre les gens en
disant ça probablement pas en 2022 j'ai
eu un mal de chien à convaincre les gens
chez moi dans ma commune à Louvier
d'aller voter Emmanuel Macron au deème
tour et je l'ai fait j'ai fait campagne
pour lui vous rendez compte ensuite on a
eu la retraite à 64 ans on a eu la
multiplication des 493 là maintenant on
a la loi immigration qui reprend les
idées de l'extrême droite donc c'est
extrêmement difficile qu'on voit bien
quand on est responsable politique on a
un devoir quand on est élu dans ces
circonstances c'est de rassembler le
pays et le pays n'a jamais été autant
divisé moi j'appelle le président de la
République à prendre une initiative pour
rassembler le pays il est le président
élu pour les 5 pour les 5 ans il a déjà
une année qui est pass
il faut que je crois il ouvre le jeu
politique qu'il écoute ce que l'on
proposeion nationale qu'il adopte des
mesures sociales dont on a besoin face à
la crise du pouvoir d'achat ce n'est pas
possible de continuer C parler pour
conclure de la sortie de crise possible
Antoine Armand ce vote m'oblige on a
tous en tête encore ces ces mots du
président de la République vous entendez
Philippe Bran qui dit ça va être
difficile sur le terrain de convaincre
s'il faut à nouveau faire barrage ça ne
sera pas Emmanuel Macron il ne se
représentera pas mais ça peut être un
candidat du bloc central c'est important
c'est un moment un moment clé tous les
moments sont clés quand le quand le pays
est bousculé et discute et d'abord je
voudrais rendre hommage à ce que vient
de dire mon collègue et et l'engagement
qui est le sien et et pardon mais je le
répète parce qu'on s'écharpe sur des
plateaux mais c'est quand même important
de savoir respecter une colonne
vertébrale républicaine quand on en
quand on en voit une il y a aujourd'hui
finalement de courant de penser dans la
manière d'affronter le rassemblement
national il y a celles et ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut continuer comme on
dit de manière un peu inélégante à le
diaboliser c'est-à-dire à en faire une
question absolument morale et considérer
et qui considère que au fond la solution
c'est de le rappeler à son héritage
historique culturel intellectuel c'est
nécessaire en partie la réalité et on
l'a reconnu tous les deux on a chacun
une part de responsabilité dans nos
courants politiques c'est que ça ne
suffit pas et donc je fais aussi partie
de ceux qui pensent que pour y arriver
pour combattre efficacement le désordre
le chaos l'incohérence faut des résultat
ut et les solutions ce que nous
demandent les gens c'est de reprendre le
contrôle démocratique c'estàdire d'avoir
des solutions en matière migratoire
d'avoir des solutions pour pouvoir
davantage produire dans notre pays pour
que les gens aient la liberté de faire
et d'agir on va terminer cette émission
avec le résumé des annonces d'Emmanuel
Macron vous le savez le chef de l'État
pendant cette émission en direct s'est
exprimé sur France 5 à l'Élysée avec
l'équipe de nos confrères de c'est à
vous et pour savoir ce qu'il a dit on
accueille tout de suite Stéphanie
desperres bonsoir Stéphanie bonsoir
alors y y a-t-il des annonces a-t-il
rassuré qu'a-t-il dit le président de la
République alors d'abord l'interview
s'est passé dans un cadre un peu
inhabituel c'était ni une allocution ni
une interview en face- à faceace mais
Emmanuel Macron était assis à la table
avec autour six journalistes de France 5
et il a répondu aux questions alors
d'abord il a évidemment défendu sa sa
loi en disant que c'était le bouclier
qui lui manquait il a remercié tous les
députés de la majorité il ne s'est pas
acharné contre ceux qui n'avaient pas
voté sa loi et il a dit que cette loi
était en fait la conséquence de la
majorité relative qui vous le savez est
présente à l'assemblée depuis juin 2022
et il a reconnu que même lui il y a des
éléments dans cette loi qu'il ne lui
convenait pas est-ce que c'est le texte
du Gouvernement vous souhitiez non bah
évidemment que non donc il y a des
choses qui me je vais pas vous dire que
je saute au plafond je les trouve
formidable ces choses il y a des choses
qui derrière par exemple bah la caution
demander honnêtement aux étudiants
étrangers je pense c'est pas une bonne
idée je vous le dis en toute sincérité
parce que je p pense qu'on a besoin de
continuer à attirer des talents des
étudiants du monde entier je pense c'est
une force de la France ça fait partie de
notre modèle dire parce que vous êtes
étranger on vous demande une caution
c'est pas le message de la France oui
mais après ça peut se retravailler et il
envisage également de retravailler la
question des prestations sociales vous
l'avez compris ça a fait beaucoup débat
ces derniers jours et puis surtout
Emmanuel Macron a voulu marquer sa
différence avec le rassemblement
national il a martelé les différences
déjà il a expliqué que lui il voulait
respecter la Constitution pas l'a
retouché et puis il a dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de préférence nationale dans
ce texte il a expliqué que le RN était
pour l'école payante pour les étrangers
que lui était contre que ce n'était pas
dans la loi même chose pour les emplois
réservés aux Français et il a expliqué
derrière qu'il assumait totalement cette
loi j'assume totalement de dire que nos
compatriotes attendaient cette loi que
si on veut que le le rassemblement
national et ses idées n'arrivent pas au
responsabilité faut traiter les
problèmes qui le nourrisse cette loi
elle va nous permettre de lutter contre
ce qui nourrit le rassemblement national
parce qu'elle va nous rendre plus
efficace parce que nos compatriotes nous
disent que aujourd'hui on ne maîtrise
pas assez bien l'immigration clandestine
va décourager les de venir s'installer
en France c'est ça la question que c'est
ce que je viens de dire très clairement
et le président a reconnu qu'il y avait
un problème d'immigration en France mais
pour lui la France n'est pas dépassée
par l'immigration alors vous connaissez
le président de la République pas
question d'être impuissant immobile dans
les prochaines années il promet de
nouvelles réformes comment pour
l'instant on ne sait pas il a promis
aussi vous le savez un grand un grand
rendez-vous au français en janvier quand
on lui a posé la question de savoir ce
que ce serait et bien il a répondu dans
un sourire nous ne sommes que le 20
décembre merci beaucoup Stéphanie
Despierre alors comment rebondir
finalement il a exactement résumé notre
émission en tout cas du point de vue de
la majorité qu'est-ce que vous réclamez
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de ce ce
grand rendez-vous de de janvier ce
rendez-vous politique qui doit tirer les
conséquences de de ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée Philippe brin ben je pense
que il faut revenir sur un certain
nombre des mesures qui ont été adoptées
on verra ce que dira le Conseil
constitutionnel je pense qu'il faut
prendre une initiative pour le pouvoir
d'achat là aujourd'hui les gens ils sont
en très grande difficulté regarder les
difficultés qu même les supermarchés
avoir des chiffres d'affaires suffisants
pour Noël les commerçants sont en
difficulté parce que les gens ont pas
d'argent les un chèque carburant un
chèque pouvoir d'achat ou même le SMIC
augmenté il faut augmenter les salaires
il faut une différence salariale pour
permettre l'augmentation des salaires il
faut des mesures pour les bas salaires
en particulier et notamment les
travailleurs du soin et du lien il y a
vraiment une attente sociale très forte
dans le pays voilà et les gens vont pas
s'en sortir avec des prix alimentaires
quion augmenter de 18 % au mois
d'octobre il faut vraiment aujourd'hui
qu'on trouve des solutions pour que les
gens puissent se nourrir puissent se
loger et c'est finalement ça leur
priorité donc ce sont des annonces que
vous attendez sur le pouvoir d'achat oui
même si les caisses sont vides ça n'est
pas des des remanements des dissolutions
des coalitions si je comprends bien pas
de réponse politique la politique tout
façon aujourd'hui il y a un parlement
qui existe qui travaille on fait des
groupes de travail transpartisan sur
plein de sujets moi j'ai voté des texte
du Gouvernement qui fonctionne donc à
vous
entendre parce que laale n'est pas le
théâtre d'ombre que monte non pas la
Chaîne parlementaire mais les chaînes
d'information en Contin continu en
vérité il y a plein de choses très bien
qui se passent à l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui ce dont on a besoin c'est
d'avoir une direction qui est
extrêmement claire pour protéger le
pouvoir d'achat des gens et aussi
défendre le service public qui à mon
avis aujourd'hui est particuliement mon
services public un coup de barre à
gauche pour le dire très clairement
qu'est-ce que vous attendez concrètement
Philippe Ballard du en fait la question
il peut y avoir une double question
c'est qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire
pour la France donc qu'est-ce qu'on
attend pour la France ou qu'est-ce que
Emmanuel Macron va voilà mais comme ça
fait 6 ans et demi qu' qu'il est dans la
comme perpétuelle on ne sait pas
d'ailleurs que pense vraiment Emmanuel
Macron mais c'est une vraie question
pour la France même pour l'étranger la
diplomatie française enfin moi je lisais
un article aujourd'hui consacré au
Proche Orient mais on comprend rien mais
rien du tout de la position française
pour l'Afrique subsaarienne on comprend
rien vous trouve n' pas de
gouvernail'est-ce que vous
attende vous vous attendez de lui un cap
social c'est très cl non mais
rien on attend 2027 3 ans et demi et on
a un projet voilà pour la France clé en
main vous aerez le mot de la fin Antoine
Armand vous vous êtes dans la majorité
mais je sais que voilà ça a tangué donc
forcément vous aussi vous avez des
attentes très concrètes sur les réformes
sur le caput peut-être même sur les
équipes gouvernementales il y a déjà un
ministre à remplacer à la santéon
d'abord les Français jugeront quand on
pose la question à un député du
rassemblement national de savoir ce
qu'il faut faire il vous répond rien je
pense que c'est quand même
assezocate et qu'attend avant 2027
chacun se fera une idée de de son mandat
parlementaire ensuite je je partage une
partie de ce qui a été dit par mon
collègue on a à la rentrée des textes
extrêmement importants j'en NME trois
l'énergie le logement l'agriculture
pourquoi ce sont des textes importants
parce que nous avons besoin de retrouver
en France la capacité de produire et de
vivre de son travail et je pense que
c'est ce que décrit Philippe brin quand
il parle de conférence salarial les
Français ne demandent pas plus d'aide à
any au grand bornan à ton à Faverge on
ne demande pas plus d'aide on demande de
meilleur salaire un travail qui rémunère
mieux et pouvoir mieux se loger et on a
à la rentrée un texte transpartisan du
Parti socialiste et de la majoritéce
après le compromis avec les républains
le compromis avec la GA 6 ans et demi 6
ans et demi quel bilan allez on verra ce
qui sera annoncé et le cap qui sera
choisi à la rentrée merci messieurs
c'était passionnant Philippe Ju a d
malheureusement nous quitter un peu plus
tôt débat très riche ce soir au
lendemain de ce vote si difficile sur
l'immigration à très vite sur LCP soirée
documentaire qui commence à présent avec
Jean-Pierre graien à demain quant à
[Musique]
moi